comes to higher education America is
second to none
world-class professors exclusive liberal
arts schools with manicured lawns and
the highest prices on the planet that is
why there's more than 1.3 trillion
dollars of student debt in the u.s.
experts think it's more student debt
than every other country in the world
combined and Americans can't afford it
there's a long list of people who think
the u.s. student loan situation is
broken how to reform it is where the
roads diverge so here's the situation
students who borrow for college and
finished in 2014 took out an average of
nearly 29 thousand dollars to pay for
their education in just the past decade
the student debt has more than tripled
rising an average of 14 percent a year
and that debt burden is rippling over
into other areas of American life with
fewer young adults buying homes new cars
getting married or starting a business
now here is the argument so what's the
real problem the cost of college or the
loans used to pay for college one school
of thought first championed by senator
Elizabeth Warren and now backed by
Hillary Clinton says part of the
solution is letting students refinance
their loans at lower interest rates a 79
percent interest rate when we haven't
had interest rates that high in years it
makes absolutely no sense president
obama has greatly expanded his own
program to offer millions of students
the opportunity to cap their monthly
student loan payments to 10% of their in
critics say making it cheaper to borrow
just makes it easier for schools to
raise tuition fees another suggestion
countries like France and Germany with
less student loan debt you would weigh
differently than America they have
higher taxes to make public universities
cheap or even free it's a solution that
isn't even on the horizon in the US
it also wouldn't help the millions of
students currently indebted to the
government for years to come